I've never seen a candidate run for an
office and basically campaign for
another candidate in the same race there
is a guy that we have been waiting for
for a long time who is a little bit
better than the other guys who's a
little bit younger and who has a bit a
little bit of a better track record who
let us out of covid and all of that
stuff and his name is Ronda santis and
he is the governor of Florida he is
America's governor um and I think he is
the best choice so now let's talk about
him for a little bit first off over the
weekend you know he doesn't get into the
drama game right if you think about all
the debates he just doesn't he he barely
got attacked in any of the debates cuz
they don't have much to cut him on and
he doesn't really attack back people you
know there were times when be and Nikki
screaming at each other and Des santis
is going you know what what's the point
of all this but he was asked
yesterday he was asked about uh this
Trump BC drama and here's how he
responded you know I noticed that they
um that he threw um um
the yeah he threw him under the bus um
you know it's like I've never seen a
candidate run for an office and
basically campaign for another candidate
in the same race before and that's
what's happened but the minute he wasn't
useful you know they they they they they
dropped the hammer on it so that's just
kind of the way way they are but look
we're going to go forward as a party we
can go forward in a way that's focused
on people's issues let focus on a great
agenda for America or we can go forward
uh with Trump which will be focused the
2024 election on legal issues on
criminal trials on convictions on on all
these things with January 6 and that
gives the Democrats um a huge Advantage
uh going forward and I don't think that
we want to do that why would we want to
give them any advantage all right the
reason I wanted to show you that clip is
as I said he doesn't really get involved
into the drama he quickly makes a
comment there and it and it's just true
right like Trump saw VC as useful you're
going to be my guy at the debates that
I'm not going to show up to and you're
going to attack everybody and say we
should always be nice and then also dump
on everybody and you're going to do all
that and then when push got to shove as
I said when we got to the 11th hour now
now Trump is going after vbec okay fine
but the real point of of showing you
that clip is what the Santa said after
which is that there is a chance to not
have all of this drama going forward
right and clearly he's the candidate to
do that by the way the two guys that
he's standing in between there Thomas
Massie uh from Kentucky and Chip Roy
from Texas Massie is by far by far not
even close the most Libertarian
liberty-minded uh Congressional member
of Congress in the entire United States
government and Chip Roy from Texas has
the number one most conservative voting
record so those guys are putting their
butts on the line nobody can question
although I guess some of the trumpkin do
whether they they are pro-america or
America first or for Maga or anything
else but what you have right there are
three decent civil servants uh fighting
together at the same
time